[Music]
I grew up and grew up in an environment that was all violence. I mean,
if I want to remember, I had no childhood, no adolescence, no
youth.
There was a child with a big boy. There was a big boy. I mean, I don’t
feel the stages that children go through. Children of the
world or people in general in all the
world. The shooting of my husband and my children. They
are...  Returning to school, my children saw their father
injured. That is, the
severe shock that my children were exposed to and the
violent reaction they had from
behind as a result of this incident. That is, it shocked me
more because it affected their behavior. It affected their personality. It
affected their academic achievement. I felt that I was
alone in that I was myself.  I am pulling my children out of
this shock, and there are no teachers who responded to us. We
started making games at home and getting the
neighbors’ kids to play with my children to play in. Later, my
children’s self-confidence increased a little. They
socialized more and organized these games in the building’s courtyard.
Academic achievement changed. Their
self-confidence began to change. After a while, I changed from...  A
completely different specialization for the basic stage because
I said that since I did not find anyone to cooperate with me from
[music]
teachers, I was me first, before I became a teacher, a psychological and social counselor,
then a teacher and educator, then we will learn that I
must deal with them with
their psychology and with their behaviors that are imposed
on them by the environment.  Or the environment intervenes in these
behaviors. They may not be violence.
Violence has different forms. It is an obstacle to the extent that
we teachers are
[music]
in our turn as well. The psychological one
and his condition does not mean that you can even
imagine the normal child or the
normal student when he refuses something difficult psychologically, so let
alone  In Karam's case too, he is already
weak, so I noticed Karam's condition. He refuses to
respond to the students, refuses to accept them, and does not play
with them. He is not hostile. Here, she came to the role of Hanan's wife. Here, her role began
with Karam. The numbers,
i.e.,
the account, started singing, started singing, sincerity in his condition, even his
voice is sweet, i.e.,
the friends became different, security changed.  I differ greatly,
and thanks to Hanan, I am not able to change his personality.
[Music]
Karam has put in my mind that I must take care of every
child who may be exposed to an accident like this and may not be
directly exposed to it. He may be beaten or
arrested at the
checkpoints of those who see the killing of those who see
on the screens.  The violence that people see on the Internet,
all social media stations see, this is
violence. This affects their behavior and affects their
academic achievement. All of this
I read in a
general [music] form for the whole family. Violence I implemented in my classroom from the first
moment. I am saying no to violence in a way that does not make
the student feel it.  With behaviors and
morals, the student learns gradually through
playing. The game has rules and regulations, and every student
in the group wants to participate in the game, whether
collectively for the whole class or as a group of figs for a class. The seas of the curriculum are for the sake of the curriculum, for the benefit of my
student, for the benefit of the
personalities of my students, for the benefit of the curriculum that I follow to
combat violence, and for the benefit of making changes in
behavior.  And by making it
easier and simpler and expanding the curriculum for the benefit of all these things
that I am telling you about or the methodology that
I am working on. We
play and learn. We play and learn. We play
[music]
and learn. You teach us a lesson in the form of a story, in the form of
a play. A
method that we understand. Hanan created
distinctive methods of reinforcement. Not excellent reinforcement
or a star. No Hanan.  Now the student has the choice to talk about his
morals, whoever wants to take the treasure, and all of
these methods have had a positive impact on the achievement of
our students, so they responded and trained. I have teachers, supervising directors, to
be informed of the method in which
I work and the approach in which I work.
Hanan imitates the spirit of the child. Hanan works on the
morals of this child, so what do you do?  Hanan has one of the
real methods that influenced and reflected
positively on Hanan’s face. A word of
thanks to her because she passed through my life because she is a
wonderful model for teachers. I learned a lot from her. The two things I
learned the most are the spirit of challenge when Miss
Hanan. We
Palestinians are a people who suffer from all obstacles, all
forms of obstacles and frustrations. We suffer from violence imposed
on us that is not in our control.  We chose it, we did not choose it. We want to
live. We want to live. We want to
live in peace. We want our children to live in peace. They can feel their
childhood. I mean, for every Palestinian teacher or
any teacher present anywhere in the world. Our job and our profession
in particular is a sublime profession. We teach all generations. We are our
powerful weapon: science. Science. Science and
education is our powerful weapon. It is what keeps us.  We
will return what was stolen from us. What was stolen from us was stolen from us in ignorance of the
ignorance that existed and we will not
[music]
take it back